let's think about the market for a
certain type of bush or a certain type
of tree that people can plant in their
gardens and here's our quantity of that
tree planted planted each year 1 million
2 million maybe this is nationwide these
are fairly large numbers for a
particular type of tree 4 million and so
forth and so on and then here let me put
the price so this is the quantity
quantity per year per year planted
planted in our country and over here
this is going to be our dollars per tree
dollars per tree and maybe this is ten
dollars this is 20 this is 30 this is 40
and our marginal cost curve for our
supply curve would look just to even get
that first tree planted to get someone
to to plant it and grow it and then
replant it in your garden you're gonna
have to pay them at least ten dollars
and then each incremental tree is going
to get a little bit more expensive and
so our marginal cost curve will look
something like that
that's our marginal cost or supply curve
and then our demand curve that very
first tree someone's going to get a huge
benefit from it and then each
incremental tree people might get a
little bit lower and lower benefit so it
might look something like this our
demand curve would look like that demand
and this is the market for a certain
nice tree nice tree and just let the if
you just let the market happen the way
it's happening right over here we get to
a very natural equilibrium quantity it
looks like it's about 2.7 million trees
planted per year and our equilibrium
price is about $20 per tree and we
generate we generate all of this total
surplus that's that split essentially
between the consumers the people who are
buying the trees and the people who are
producing the trees now let's say that a
research study comes out and this
particular breed of trees the nice tree
it turns out has all of these benefits
to it so let's say that it's it does it
has you know some it's somehow related
to pest control maybe all the pests that
people don't like when they eat this
bark they go away or something
that the mosquitos go away and you know
do you get less disease let's say it
also improves air quality air quality
and let's say on top of that it's just
it's just nice-looking so you know even
even if it's not your tree you pass it
by in a neighborhood it just calms your
nerves and makes you feel better about
the world so they are just nice nice to
look at to look at and this study that
these researchers conduct they
determined that the benefit of all of
these things of the pest control and the
air quality and the just the aesthetic
benefit of society at large comes out
over the life of a tree to ten dollars a
tree so it is ten dollars ten dollars
per tree per tree benefit so the is
essentially saying that above and beyond
the benefit that the owner of the garden
gets there's a societal there's an
external benefit and so you can imagine
we're now talking about positive
externalities there's an external
benefit of planting the tree that
amounts to ten dollars per tree so how
would we factor that in how do we
determine if just right just given this
equilibrium price and quantity whether
we we really are we do really have the
optimal number of trees in society well
in the past we in the last few videos we
had a negative externality we had a
external cost and so we added that cost
to the cost curve now we have an
external benefit we have a positive
externality so we can add this this
benefit to the marginal benefit curve so
essentially this is the benefit that the
buyers of the tree are getting and to
that let's add the benefit that society
is getting so society is getting ten
dollars more benefit so this for
millions a tree or it's actually a
little bit lower looks like it's about
three and a half million three there's
ten dollars of benefit but if you
combine it with society's benefit so
another ten dollars you would get up
here and so you would essentially and
this first tree it looks like it's
almost fifty dollars of benefit but if
you add society's benefit it's actually
closer to 60 dollars a benefit and so
you're essentially taking this demand
curve and you're shifting it up by ten
dollars when you are factoring in the
benefit when you are factoring in the
benefit to society
so that up there and you could call this
you could call this the marginal benefit
plus the external plus the external
benefit curve so it's factoring in all
of the the benefit that society is
getting by these trees planted but when
you look at that curve you get a
slightly different equilibrium price you
get a slightly different equilibrium
price the equilibrium price goes all the
way out here so now the equilibrium
pressure goes up to this the equilibrium
price looks closer instead of $20 at $27
and the quantity the quantity actually
produced looks closer to 3.3 million and
so if we just let the market happen
without factoring in this benefit in
some way we're essentially leaving all
the table leaving on the table all of
this all of the surplus that could have
happened if we just let the market
settle in on its on it's natural price
in equilibrium and equilibrium quantity
equilibrium price and equilibrium
quantity we're going to produce this 2.7
million and so the total benefit to
society is going to be this whole curve
right or you can say society's benefit
is going to be this right over here the
consumers benefit is going to be is
going to be this part right over here
and then actually this part all the way
over here because our equilibrium prices
gets right over there and then the
producers surplus is this is that right
over there but we're leaving some
societal benefit on the table we are
leaving if you think of it from
society's point of view you can view
this orange area as a deadweight loss
we're leaving that on the table if we
don't somehow create an incentive for
more of these trees to be produced and
so in this situation a way to make the
optimal quantity produce in order for
society to get this surplus what they
could do is in the case of a negative
externality we imposed a tax that
factors in the negative externality now
we could put some type of a subsidy we
could say hey if you plant a tree if if
someone plants a tree plants a tree buys
and plants one of these trees you will
get a $10 tax credit $10 tax credit so
it's essentially saying whoever plants
one of these trees their taxes are going
to be $10
lower than what they would have
otherwise had paid and so essentially
they're saying look whatever benefit you
were going to get from the tree we're
going to give you ten dollars more
benefit for that and so you're
essentially you're essentially making
sure that the optimal quantity is being
produced now in that circumstance you're
essentially giving all of the marginal
benefit that extra $10 benefit you're
giving it you're giving it to the people
who are planting the trees so
essentially all of this all of this
becomes their benefit as well because
they are going to get the ten dollars
but the good thing is at least at least
that positive surplus is getting is
going to someone it's not being lost
you're not giving up you're not giving
up on this orange area right over there